[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا نحيكم
الى بانوراما كالعاده نناقش ابرز الملفات
اليوم
الانتخابات في الكونجرسح للرئاسه لماذا
اختار هذا التوقيت وهل تنجح اسرتيته في
ازاحه خصومه الثلاث الرئيسيين
غربيه في التعامل مع ازمه الصواريخ التي
سقطت في بولندا
ماذا تعني ردود الافعال هذه وهل يتقارب
الروس والغرب على حسابه اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لم ينتهي الجدل بعد بشان نتائج انتخابات
التجديد النصفي في الكونجرس حتى فجاه
دونالد ترامب اعلان ترشحه للرئاسه لعام
2024 رغم خساره من دعمهم ترامب وعدم تحقيق
اغلبيه كاسحه في مجلس النواب كما كان
متوقعا وحمل الجمهوريون ترامب المسؤوليه
عن الفشل على الانتخابات او في الانتخابات
غير انه لم يكترس لدعوات من جمهوريين
بتراجع بعد ما جاءت نتائج الانتخابات
منتصف الولايه غير مرضيه للحزبه ويتوقع ان
تمهد اوراق وترامب التي تم تقديمها امام
هيئه الانتخابات الفيدراليه الامريكيه
لمعركه قاسيه داخل الحزب الجمهوري لنيل
بطاقه الترشح للرئاسه من جانبه رد رئيس
الامريكي على اعلان دونالد ترامب ان رئيس
الجمهوريه السابق خذل بلاده خلال دوره
منصبه بايضا قال ان خلال رئاسه ترامب تربع
خير على عرش اقتصاد مزور لصالح الاثرياء
وهاجم النظام الصحي ودلل المتطرفين وهاجم
حقوق المراه وحرض العصابه العنيفه من اجل
محاوله قلب فوزي بعيدا عام 2020 الى خساره
وينظر الى اعلان ترامب على انه يهدف الى
تبديل فرص اي من منافسه المحتملين بمن
فيهم رمزي سانتنس حاكم فلوريدا الذي حذره
ترامب من الترشح وكذلك نائبه السابق
[موسيقى]
كمان كمان
[تصفيق]
ادويه امريكا
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من اورلاندو
وتوم حرب ريس وتحالف الامريكي الشرق
اساطير الديمقراطيه اهلا بك ومن هو احمد
الحمصيه الباحث في الشان الامريكي اهلا
بكمين واسم حالي ان ابدا من اورلاندو معك
سيتم سيد توم الباص طرح تساؤلات عديده فما
يخص التوقيت توقيت اعلان ترامب في الواقع
احداث جدلا في داخل الامريكي وخارجه خاصه
بان ترامب سبق الاعلان النهائي عن نتائج
همم الكونجرس الخاصه بمجلس الشيوخ وحتى
جوله الاعاده في جورجيا في ديسمبر المقبل
لماذا اختار التوقيت هل استبق فعلا همم
توقيت همم جيد
وهل هذا التوقيت سيخدمه تعتقد
مرحبا ريمو مرحبا من الضيفه الكريمه احمد
والمشاهدين الكرام هلا بالتوقيت يعني هذه
الفتره يبدا المرشحين الذين ينهون الترشح
الى رئاسه جمهوريه قبل عيد الميلاد اما
قبل راس السنه اما ما بعد هذه الفتره هلا
بدون شك هو يعتبر انه اذا سيكون له
منافسين من الحزب الجمهوري ربما راندي
سانتوس حاكم ربما دائره السابق
فكرر الخاص بهذه المعركه
واذا قرر الخاطر ربما الباقيين لم يترشحوا
بال 2016 كان المن المترشحين 16 شخصيه
واكثر ربما وهمم والتقى الشعب الامريكي
صوت له بالانتخابات
تمهيديه الى فتره سنه ونص ومن يحب ان
يشارك من الحزب الجمهوري في الانتخابات ال
همم التمهيديه الس مفتوحه للجميع ولكن
استاذ احمد هذا لن يضر
بداخل وبتركيبه الحزب الجمهوري خاصه وانا
الانتقادات التي تعرض لها دونالد ترامب
بانتقادات لم تاتي فقط من الديمقراطيين
اتته من معارضيه فذخل في داخل الحزب
الجمهوري هل استباقه لمنافسين من داخل
الحزب الجمهوري واعلانه لترشحه سيؤثر على
الحزب تعتقد
يعني ترامب لديه مشكلتين الان هما ما
دفعتها يعني للتسرع او يعني مو ضروري
التسرع يعني بس للاعلان مبكرا جدا المشكله
الاولى تحقيقات يعني لتجري تحقيقات
القانونيه ترامب يحتاج ان يضع صفه مرشح
سياسي تحت اسمه لتوفير نوع من الحمايه
القانونيه انه يعني بحيث تصنف بعض هذه
التحقيقات على انها محاوله لاقصائي سياسيا
وليس لادانه جنائيه المشكله الثانيه انه
يرى ارقام ديستانس ترتفع يعني ببطء ولكن
بثبات طوال السنه الماضيه هناك استطلاعات
ظهرت مؤخرا يعني تظهر ان الانسان اعلى من
ترامب يعني بيفارق بسيط في التاييد داخل
الحزب الجمهوري طبعا هذا لا يعني ان ترامب
ضعيف او انه غير قادر على السيطره ولكنه
يخشى اذا انتظر ان تزداد شعبيه اكثر واكثر
وبالتالي فرصته اكثر في اسيطر على الحزب
ان يصبح يعني هو المرشح الاول حتى ولكن
ترشحوه للسيف يفتح باب صراع كبير داخل
جمهوري خلال السنتين القادمهتين
تسرع او اعلن مبكرا كما يقول ضيفي
السيد ترامب رئيس ترامب اللي هو فتره يقول
انه سيكون لي مفاجات وهنالك له شعبيه
كبيره ضمن الحزب الجمهوري هلا بالنسبه
للانتخابات التي حصلت كان هنالك ربما
انتقاد من الجمهوريين ضدهم هؤلاء
الجمهوريين التقليديين اول نتائج
الانتخابات او الاسبوع الماضي كان اتهامات
اكثر ما هي اليوم وبعد التحليلات والوقائع
انتقلت ال همم الانتقامات اما النقد الى
الرئيس همم الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ مش
مقام واليوم بداوا يضعون
اللام عليه هم لم يدعم المرشحين في مجلس
الشيوخ فلذلك الامر خاسر الجمهوريون اما
ب- بمجلس النواب فمن الواضح بان الاكثريه
ستكون لمصلحه
الجمهوريين
وتنتقل المطرقه من يد الديمقراطيين الى
الحزب الجمهوري وهذا انتصار طبعا لم تكن
هنالك الموجه الحمراء الذين يتكلموا عليها
ولكن هذه الموجه الحمراء ربما كان سيكون
لها سيف من حداد يعني كان الشعب سيعتبر
انه اين النواب الجمهوريين لم يفعلوا شيء
وان كانوا فازوا بالكميه قليله ربما الشعب
لم يركز عليهم مثل ما يركز على اداره بيدل
وسياساتها اللي بعد سنتين
او كيف تقلب الاخفاقات الى انجازات يعني
حضرتك ههه تعتبر بانه حتى الفوز على مستوى
مجلس النواب همم بفارق فضائي قد يستخدمه
الجمهوريون لصالحهم في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه كيف ترى الموضوع استاذ احمد هل
هذا واقع ممكن
لا نعتقد ان خساره الجمهوريه لمجلس النواب
افضل بالنسبه لهم من هذا يعني الفوز
الضعيف لانه الفوز ضعيف سيجعلهم مشلولين
وسيشغلون بصراعاتهم الداخليه اكثر لانه
لدينا الان تيارين داخل الحزب الجمهوري
يعني يتكلم داخل مجلس النواب لدينا
الفريدون كوكس
والمعروفه بالتشدد انها تريد
يمثلون ضغط كبير على اداره على اداره
الجمهوريين داخل المجلس في المقابل لدينا
اعضاء جدد دخلوا في بالذات من نيويورك
وقد يلحق بها من كاليفورنيا ومن ولايات
مختلفه هذه هؤلاء معتدلين قادمين من مناطق
معتدله يعرفون جيدا انه اذا ذهب الحزب نحو
التشدد ونحو المشاكل سيخسرهم مقاعدهم في
24 لذلك سيحاولون اذا لم يعطلفهم على
الاقل سيبتعده والقائد الحزب الجمهوري
غالبا سيكون كارثي لا يستطيع اي صوت الى
جمعيه ولا نعرف انه مكارثي ليس بمصي وليس
مقالا هو ليس قائد قويا يستطيع التحكم
يعني بقياده همم الكاكس حقه بشكل جيد فما
بالك عندما يكون في هذا الموقف الحساس جدا
اليوم لن نتحدث فقط عن مايكبان سنتحدث عن
حكم فلوريدا ديسانس ولكن نتحدث كذلك عن
اسماء اخرى بعض الجمهوريون او الجمهوريين
عفوا يقترحوها مثل سفيره الامم المتحده
سابقا لكهان مثل سيناتور تيمسكوت ومجموعه
اخرى من الاسماء بهذه التركيب وباستباق
ترامب الاعلان عن ترشحها هل يمكن ان اتحدث
عن حسابات جديده داخل حزب الجمهوريين هل
هناك معادله مختلفه قادر الحزب على
تقديمها
حتى هذه الساعه
ربما المنافس القوي ضد الرئيس ترامب سيكون
راندي سانتوس بقيه الاشخاص مع كل الاحترام
لهم لا يسم لهم القدره والكاريزما
للجمهور الامريكي مثل الرئيس ترامب وادي
سانتوس ولكن الرئيس ترامب جرب على الساحه
الدوليه والشعب الامريكي يعرف انه كيف
توازن النظام الاقتصادي والتجاري الدولي
وكيف اليوم بعهد الرئيس تنافس بالحروب
ولما دخول على حرب نوويه هذا
التنافقون فقط
تتحدث عن الكاريزما سناتي على مناقشتها
بعد قليل ولكن تحدث عن القدره همم قدره
ترامب في حل ايه مشاكل لانه بعدها كذلك من
جهته ساره الى وضع ملفات يقول راب اخفق
فيها تحدث عن انه دلل المتطرفين اثر بحقوق
المراه اثر بقطاع الصحه وغيرها من
القطاعات فقدرته على مذهب التحديد اين
قدره ترامب كما تراها
ظلله للمراه لا عين ثلاث قضاه للقضاء
الاعلى واعاده موضوع الاجهاض الى الولايات
وليس من مصلحه القضاء الاعلى هذا الذي
وضعه وهذا الذي طلبه الشعب الامريكي ولذلك
الامر هل هناك مجموعه ضد هذه النظريه
فلتتحكم بها الولايات وليس المحكمه
القدراليه
على الموضوع الداخلي يعني لما ترك الرئيس
ترامب سده الرئاسه كان برميل للنصب 60
دولار اليوم برميل النفط حوالي 100$ لما
ترك ترامب كان كانت تضخم الماليه واحد فقط
ثمانيه ايام ثمانيه بالمئه فهذه الاستاذه
يعني الشعب الامريكي يراها بالعين المجرده
وسينتخب لاجل لها بعد ثنتين من اليوم
لمصلحه الشعب الامريكي فنتصور يعني سبب
نجاح ترامب سيكون هو التخفيق وسياسه
الرئيس بيدن سنتين الماضيتين والسنتين
القادمه
مفهوم ان تاتي هذه المطالب من
الديمقراطيين هم يتحدثون عن همم مشاكل
ابعد من ذلك استاذ احمد يتحدثون عن
الديمقراطيه هم يضعون ميزان الديمقراطيه
ضمن موازين همم الحسابات الداخليه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ضيف يتحدث عن
الكاريزما وكذلك هذا سؤال يطرح وكان
الكاريزما اليوم قد تربح شخصا على حساب
شخص اخر همم يدعي بانه يدافع على
الديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبالتالي باين باي عين يرى
الناس همم هذه الملفات اذا وضعتها في
مقابل بعضها البعض
يعني ترامب بكل كارز ما اتفقش في ثلاث
دورات متتاليه في تحقيق فوز انتخابه يعني
في 18 و20 و22 ترامب يسيطر على قاعده
الحزب الجمهوري بقوه ولكنه ليس يعني ليس
قائد سياسي دوده شعبيه على مستوى الشعب
لذلك الجمهوريين يحاولون التخلص من بشكل
سلمي ولكن الايام اثبتت انهم غير قادرين
على ذلك في السؤال الذي امامنا الان هل
سيتخلصون منه بالقوه ام سيستسلمون كما
فعلوا سابقا بالنسبه لبائد هناك قطاعات
كبيره داخل الحزب الديمقراطي يعني غير
راضيه تماما عنه لكن راينا بمجرد بمجرد
ظهور هو ان نتائج انتخابات 22 هناك ارتفاع
كبير من داخل الديمقراطيين يعني حتى ال-
ال- ال- ال- اليسريين يعني اكثر اليسار
وهم المعرضين الرئيسيين الانصار ساندرس
كلهم مستقينا الان خلف بعض لانهم يرون انه
تحديدا في قضيه الديمقراطيه عندما كان
الجميع يقول لبايدا يجب ان تتحدث عن
الاقتصاد وعن التضخم وان تضخم مشكله
عالميه وكل الحجج هذا تركهم كلهم وخرجت كل
خطاباته تتحدث عن الديمقراطيه وخرج فائزا
يعني من معركه كان يتوقع فيها ان تكون
خسارته فادحه فهذا كل شيء سيقوي حدود
الديمقراطيين كثيرا وسي- يساعد اكثر على
تماسك الحزب خلال سنتين القادمهتين لدخول
على الانتخابات 24 في وضع جيد تراه خاسر
سيد احمد خلف في انتخابات 2014
الاشكاليه الكبرى في 24 انها ما زالت
بعيده امامنا سنتين سنتين في يعني في عمر
سياسه تعتبر ظهر طويل جدا كثير ايضا الحزب
الجمهوري مهما كان موظفا مهما كانت
الصراعات يعني تمزق المنظمه كبيره قويه
يعني
كما نقول مثلا الشعبي في الماء همم
دونالد ترامب ليس بهذا القياد السياسي همم
اللي ممكن يقود لمرحله اخرى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والعالم همم سيد همم هل
توافق ضيفي لانه كذلك يرى بان كل همم او
بكل الكاريز ما التي يحملها ترامب ولكنه
اخفق في العظميه ملفات
ترامب
توازن دولي تجاري لمصلحه امريكا ولم يقود
اي حرب كان هو من الرؤساء القلائل في
الولايات المتحده لم يدخلوا باي حرب في اي
مكان في العالم فهذا نجاح له اما بالتوازن
التجاري الذي عقده بين امريكا والمكسيك
وكندا كان له الفضل الكبير كذلك مع مع
الصين لحد ما الماء ولكن
الحدود الامريكيه ال- ال- مع المكسيك
وتوقيف
الكفته جون والمخدرات كل هذه الاعمال
لمصلحه الشاعر الامريكي لحتى اليوم لم
نعرف الرئيس
الامريكي ذاهبين اليوم ثمانيه
لموضوع التغيير المناخي وهم على شفيع حرب
نوويه فاين فاين التغيير المناخي بعد 300
سنه اليوم واين الحرب النوويه اذا اصروا
على على هذه السياسه الخارجيه
والتخبطات والمشاكل الدوليه هذه كلها يعني
الشعب الامريكي سيختارها في نهايه المطاف
بعد سنتهم اليوم وانا اتفق معك الاستاذ
احمد السنتان هي طويله بالمجالس السياسي
ولكن الذي بدا بسنتين مرتين اليوم
بالاخطاء لا يستطيع ان يغير السياسه
بطريقه افضل الا اذا اتوا الجمهوريون
بمجلس النواب وقيدوا دار الرئيس وربما
سيفعلون ذلك يعني بان مثاليه لمصلحه الشعب
الامريكي اما دعم همم غير بدون اي قيود لا
اوكرانيا وبنعرف الرئيس الاوكراني امبارح
كان ولا حرب عالميه ثالثه على شويه فهذه
الاسماء يعني هذا الجبل السياسي في
السياسه الخارجيه يعطي الشعب لامريكا نوع
من نظريه جديده واعاده النظر بانتقاب
رئيسه الخاص احمد بان
ماسا يمنع ديمقراطين من الفوز بانتخابات
24 ضيف يتحدث عن اا فشل في اداره السياسه
الخارجيه ويتحدث عن بعض بالتحديد يقول ما
فشل في سنتين مضيتين في اداره ملفات جد
مهمه لم ينجح ولم يتمكن من ترميم هذه
الملفات فما تبقى له من الوقت
جزئيه بس انا لم اقل انك ترامب فشل في
الاداره ولا ما قال لنا بعيد النجاح في
الاداره انا قلت لهم فشل انتخابيه لا
يهمني ان اقنع المشاهد بافضليه او يعني
عدم افضليه اي مرشح سياسي ما يهمني ان
اقرا الشارع ما الذي يحدث فعلا حاليا
ترامب اضعف منها ان يستطيع بالفوز
بالانتخابات قد يتغير هذا ولكن تغيره صعب
بينما بايضا قادر تماما على الفوز
وحتى موضوع انه رئيس يعيد من جديد او يعاد
انتخابه من جديد بعد اخفاقه في ولايه هذا
همم في تاريخ الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يمكن استثناء كليفلاند فقط هو اللي فاز
همم او همم حصل على مثل هكذا همم امكانيه
ولكن التاريخ
لا يذهب فيها كذا اتجاه صحيحه استاذ احمد
صحيح ولكن لا يمكن قياس كثيرا عن التاريخ
لاننا نعيش في مرحله مختلفه تماما دائما
عندما تفشل قياده حزب سياسي في تحقيق
انتصارات انتخابيه فان يتم استبدالها يتم
وضعها جانبا وابرز قيادات جديده تقد لي
توجهات جديده لتحقيق الفوز مجددا ولكن هذا
لم يحدث في الحزب الجمهوري يعني كان
المفروض يحدث بعد 2020 ولكن المشكله التي
يعانيها رئيس الجمهوري للاسف التي يعني
الحزب الجمهوري ان قائده ممثلا في ترامب
بيقول انا ومن بعده طوفان ووراءه القطاع
على الاقل على الاقل 30% من الناخبين
الحزب اذا لم يكن اكثر يصرخون يعني همم
نموت نموت ويحيى ترامب فبالتالي هم لم
يستطيعوا تجنيبه للراس قيادات جديده ولن
يستطيع الفوز معه هذه الاشكاليه تواجهم
الان ويحتاجون لحلها جدري اما بتقويه
ترامب او بتخلص منها رغم كل شيء لا نعرف
ما الذي سيفعلون يعني نظريا هم يفترض ان
يستبدون وقت ممكن ولكن انا لا نثق بشجاعته
وقدره على ذلك
الاستاذ توم همم هل سيتم تقويه ترامب ام
سيتم فصله ابعاده وهل حزب الجمهوري كما
يقول ضيفه ويطرح نفس هذا الاستفهام الذي
يطرحه مراقبون قادر على همم طرح همم رؤيه
تاثير او فرض على الاقل راي في داخل الحزب
الله
سيكون من الشعب الامريكي بالانتخابات
التمهيديه عند الحزب الجمهوري وهذا وهذه
عده الديمقراطيه ولكن الذي نراه اليوم منذ
مجيء الرئيس ترامب يعني من سنه انا
بانتخابات ال220 الشعب اللاتيني والشعب
الاسود صوت الجمهوريين اكثر من اي فتره
سابقه واذا بقينا على هذا
الامتياسي ربما سيتفوق الرئيس ترامب لانه
الانعاش الاجتماعي هو لمصلحه الشعب
الامريكي والشركات الصغيره ومعظمه هذا
الشركات الصغيره هي ارباب عيال صغيره في
المجتمع الامريكي وانا اتصور هذا سيكون
الرئيس
اخذ سياسه الحزب الديمقراطي اليوم الى
اليسار التقدم اليسار التقدم هو تغيير
المناهج المدرسيه تغيير قضايا كثيره في
المجتمع الامريكي اليوم المراهقين الاطفال
انه بدهم يغيروا لهم الجنس حسب الاولاد شو
بدهم وليس للعائله وليس للاب والامن وهذا
سيرفظه المجتمع الامريكي التيار التيار
اليسار اخذ البلاد الجامعه بجرها لمشاكل
سنقع بها بعد سنتين و اربع سنين وست سنين
وانا اتمنى لهذا الحد ويعود او منطق
الامريكي الى الوسط وليس الى اليسار
الامور سواء داخل الحزب الجمهوري او كذلك
على مستوى التحضيرات للانتخابات شكرا لكم
احمد الحنطيه الباحث في الشان الامريكي
شكرا جزيلا على المشاركه
[موسيقى]